it's a shocking turn of event for people
living in the West Bank the Israel
Defense Forces says it shot and killed
three Hamas members inside of a hospital
in the city of Janine Tuesday video
released by hamas's military Wing shows
IDF soldiers dressed as Muslim women and
medics in the undercover
operation in Gaza humanitarian needs
continue growing more than 85% of the
territory's population has been dis
spaced following hamas's October 7th
attack with Aid trickling
in this woman says we've been left on
the streets the hungry you remain hungry
she added that eating a piece of bread
would feel like something
sweet dozens of Israeli protesters held
up Aid trucks Crossing from Egypt as
they apply pressure on Hamas to release
dozens of hostages all of this comes as
several Nations have paused funding to
the UN agency assisting Palestinian
refugees we did the responsible thing
which is to pause pending an
investigation Canada and the US are
among the countries that have held Aid
to unra after allegations some of its
staff participated in the October 7th
attacks on Tuesday the government
announced it will send $40 million of
Aid to Gaza through different channels
we appeal to donors not to suspend their
funding to unra at this critical moment
cutting off funding will only hurt the
people of Gaza who desperately need
support the World Health Organization
and un Secretary General are appealing
to donors to ensure funding continues to
flow through unra US officials say
fundamental changes are needed before
funding can restart this all comes as
Hamas and Israel consider a mediated
truce according to Reuters while in an
Israeli West Bank settlement prime
minister Benjamin Netanyahu says he's
committed to nothing less than absolute
Victory he noted Israel will not
withdraw its military from Gaza or free
thousands of Palestinian prisoners a
demand made by Hamas unless all of its
objectives are met those objectives
include the elimination of Hamas Kyle
Benning Global News